leur pays est envahi leur capital est en
état de siège ils répondent à l'appel
pour ces sommes des civils il est temps
de prendre les armes pour défendre kiev
avec l'avancée des forces russes la
ville doit distribuer dix huit mille
armes pour permettre à qui le souhaitent
de les combattre
pensais qu'ils allaient nous intimité
ils ont raté dit alex est venu s'enrôler
ce matin il a 35 ans n'a jamais tenu une
arme de sa vie mais pour lui c'est un
devoir ils sont très nombreux à se
porter volontaires mais ça ne suffira
pas pensent les autorités aujourd'hui
ils ont annoncé que les hommes de 60 à
65 ans pouvait aussi se porter
volontaire s'ils se sentent en forme
physique à leurs risques et périls
il n'y a pas d'alternative pour
l'ukraine dit ce recruteur l'europe
devrait aussi comprendre que c'est pour
eux que les ukrainiens se bat hugo rue
mai prochain
je ne leur pardonnerai jamais de forcer
les habitants de kiev à se terrer dans
le métro dit il
ça je ne peux pas le 9 juillet
la fatigue la faim la peur se lit sur
les visages des centaines d'habitants de
kiev qui s'apprête à passer une deuxième
nuit dans ce qui est devenu le dernier
refuge contre l'offensive russe
d'achat et sa famille j'ai un compris
ont choisi cette station du centre parce
que c'est la plus profonde de kiev
[Musique]
je ne sais pas comment on en est arrivé
là on est très fatigués dit elle tout ça
les émotions la peur l'incertitude de ce
que sera demain on a très peur
et pour cause aux premières heures du
matin des explosions ont retenti dans
une ville qui ne dormaient sans doute
déjà pas le ciel encore obscures s'est
illuminé de rouge parmi les victimes des
affrontements des civils que vladimir
poutine dit pourtant être venu défendre
cette vidéo a fait la ronde des réseaux
sociaux dans un quartier de l'ouest de
kiev on y voit un blindé rouler sur une
voiture dans des circonstances
difficiles à déterminer
miraculeusement le conducteur a survécu
et des voisins ont accouru pour
l'extirper de ce qui a bien failli
devenir son cercueil
avec à peine plus que le désespoir pour
bagages des milliers d'habitants de la
capitale tenter un dernier effort pour
fuir
des tirs pour disperser une foule de
plus en plus près de céder à la panique
foot arriver à passer mais comment faire
avec un enfant demande maria le chien
peur c'est dangereux et nous ne
partirons pas ce résultat elle je n'ai
pas l'énergie pour attendre le prochain
jeu n'est juste plus d'énergie
la force qui leur restent ils espèrent
la donner à ceux qui portent l'uniforme
leur héros ceux qui ne peuvent pas fuir
qui ne peuvent pas tomber c'est à eux
que s'est adressé vladimir poutine dans
la journée accusant leur dirigeante des
pires défaillance morale en paris vous
du pouvoir ce sera plus facile pour nous
d'en arriver à une entente leur at-il
dit qu'avec cette bande de drogués et de
néo nazis qui retiennent la population
en otage à kiev leader
nous sommes tous ici nos militaires sont
ici les citoyens de la société aussi
nous défendons tous notre indépendance
notre pays et cela le restera lui a
rétorqué volodymyr zelensky
kiev n'est pas sur le point de retourner
son arme contre lui quoi qu'en pense le
président russe
[Musique]
la nuit tombe et qui avait est de
nouveau secoué par le bruit
assourdissant des explosions répétées
beaucoup plus tôt que la veille beaucoup
plus fréquentes le président ukrainien
s'est une fois de plus adressé à ses
concitoyens
l'ennemi va utiliser toutes ses forces
pour briser notre résistance at il
prévenu ils seront cruel inaugure ce
soir ils vont lancer une attaque en
règle il faut rester fort le sort de
l'ukraine se décide maintenant si ma
nuit sera très sombre et difficile mais
le jour va se lever at il ajouté
et avec lui une question demeure alors
que les militaires russes ont déjà un
pilot g dans la porte de la capitale
la volonté les armes la fierté et le
patriotisme des ukrainiens suffiront ils
à les sauver
ici marie-eve bédard radio canada qui m